Joe Biden was at Rafael warnock's church
and there were some real spiritual hymns
going on people were moving they were
flowing they were clapping
Joe Biden couldn't move there he is you
see all the choir in the background
singing about the spirit and Biden
doesn't know what to do
even Warnock he's clapping
[Music]
everybody out there in the congregation
The Voice Biden who raises his hand
uh
hmm
what do I do that is not a man who has
ever
seriously attended a black Protestant
church it's like the opening scene of
the jerk with Steve Martin I was born a
poor black child and then he's he's
there and the way that he finds out he's
adopted it's because he can't he can't
dance because he doesn't have any rhythm